let me put my [ __ ] back in I'll figure
it out later never back your back like
this because then you're gonna be able
to claim you're gonna be like oh my god
what have I done what up G Q this is
Afrojack and these are my essentials
[Music]
they're prescription sunglasses so I
actually see more with them than without
them but it also kind of hide my eyes so
like it always goes like extra sense of
privacy like my little invisibility
cloak this is our secret but like I only
play with shades on like if I'm not sure
about what's going to happen exactly at
the show or if I'm playing for a new
crowd or something so if you see me
playing with my shades on that means
like kind of nervous there's the hair
hider the nice thing about a head is
that you never have to do your you just
put on the head and you're looking sharp
they have a couple of stores in Tokyo
which only sell hats and they have like
all kinds of hats for less time I got
there about like 60 hats that's like my
collection is like a hundred hundred
fifty hats if you want to look fly we go
for the snapback if you want to be like
I don't care then like go for the bad
hat and like put it like this I'm a
PlayStation 4 I've always been a gamer
since I was a kid even though I'm very
busy with making music I still get into
a good game of called QD every now and
then fortnight and Gran Turismo just
like racing we play on the jet sometimes
like I had a friend of mine design
special suitcase and there's like a
PlayStation 4 and 2 controllers in it so
we play on the chat a lot I think it's
very important also in life that like
you play as much as you work make sure
to always have fun
next piece very simple a mini wallet
credit cards a lot of ID cards a lot of
different driver's licenses from
different countries
I travel lots I like to get my driving
permit everywhere I do
discover this until about two years ago
before that I was carrying around this
like big wallet it's a good invention
the mini wallet
[Music]
in Holland Dave is saying to actually
call it clipping like when you like show
off a change look at my money I rather
have you like me for me noise cancelling
headphones this is like the best
invention of all time I wear this on the
plane I wear this when I'm in the car
where it is actually everywhere like if
I put it all right now I don't hear any
background noise so it completely puts
me like in my own zone so if you combine
this with the head and the sunglasses
like
[Music]
it doesn't work at festivals because
like the base frequency makes them freak
out or something but like anywhere in
regular life even if you're standing
next to ten people waiting in line at
Starbucks just like waiting for you to
get your banana bread or getting your
coffee
put these on your in your own song to DJ
I use send Isis they look very crappy
but they are they are the best just blew
all my chances for any DJ headphone
sponsoring ever the best port this is my
second Passport
if you travel a lot it's actually
possible to request a second passport I
have a visa for the Kingdom of Thailand
the Republic of India UAE
is like eight China visas in depth or
more for the Russian Federation my
favorite place in the world is Japan I
can feel from Europe or from America you
ever want to like experience a different
world go to Tokyo everyone's respectful
everyone's nice kind of the way it's
supposed to be probably but whatever
like Tokyo is don't here's the place
almost professional this is my home
studio set up like as a keyword used
sometimes I have speakers that I use
sometimes but 99% of the time it's this
my headphones and just me working on it
that's it
this is two USB hubs other tune called
the F resume don't want for Nexus for
all my plugins that I use on my laptop
and four terabytes of extra space so
basically this is like my studio this is
what I use to make music on to check my
emails watch stuff on YouTube everything
happens on this laptop yeah I would
definitely recommend everyone that
travels a lot to use this fel-pro stuff
because else you have like all your hard
disks hanging on the side and stuff like
make it stuck I think it's broken
oh it's working
so this is working it's fine so I guess
it looks really funny if you look at it
for the first time but this is actually
your
peon plug I have like ten of these going
from Europe to America America to Africa
Africa to Asia England UK like this is
very important where you're traveling a
lot because else of course you can
charge your phone you can charge your
lips if you can't charge anything so you
always bring a set of fees definitely an
essential piece for the traveling life
stuff
hello no I'm just joking this is of
course a very essential item and like
I'm not gonna waste too much time
talking about what it is just like
everyone else in the world we do
everything on our phone we live on her
phone we eat on her phone we sleep on
her phone phone phone phone phone phone
I use whatsapp a lot course Instagram
worth Kinect fortnight Evernote and I
have a lot of audiobooks this is all
audiobooks I do that a lot
what's in the bag this is Tom berry for
fancy he's my homie he goes everywhere
so this bag has all my stuff in it if
all my luggage would get lost
I'd be fine as long as I have this and
even when I'm at airport so I'm about to
sit down I'm kind of tired
I tie it around my leg to make sure that
if I fall asleep like Noah can go like
your everything's in it this might like
DJ headphones my charger my big wallet
splitter in case someone else hear the
music jewelry sometimes you have people
that see a lot of value in those things
so you get them the table you got a car
that's a nice watch you must be very
good at what you do let's do this deal
just like that's how some people work so
don't don't hate the player hate the
game more noise cancelling headphones
Apple pen a normal pen nail clipper I
finally quit biting my nails after like
years of biting my nose so my best
friend I told him like every time you
see me buy my nails just like punch me
in the shoulder there's still kind of
crappy but like at least they're long so
this is some essential stuff
I don't know you know what I think what
you need to travel the world safely and
be very happy in life
wow it's not about you we good thank you
for watching
see you
[Music]